hallo und willkommen zu ZDF heute live
sie war nach Kriegsbeginn die erste und
einzige Gebietshauptstadt unter
russischer Kontrolle es geht um herson
aber das ist Vergangenheit seit heute
Wehen dort wieder die ukrainischen
Flaggen und das ist das Thema das uns
heute beschäftigt der russische Rückzug
aus Hessen und seine Folgen wie schwer
wiegt diese Niederlage für Moskau und
natürlich auch für Vladimir Putin ja und
die Bilder die aus Herr Sonne und
Umgebung über die sozialen Netzwerke um
die Welt gehen heute die haben es schon
in sich das sind große Emotionen und sie
zeigen eine jubelnde Bevölkerung die
können wir uns gerne mal gemeinsam
anschauen
hubkonzerte Jubelschreie Umarmungen und
küsse viele der verbliebenen Einwohner
von Person haben den Abzug der
russischen Truppen gefeiert Bilder und
Videos in den sozialen Medien zeigen wie
gesagt wie etwa die blau-gelbe Flagge
wieder auf den Gebäuden gehst wird und
die ukrainische Soldaten begeistert
empfangen werden Russland wiederum hat
mitgeteilt dass keine russischen
Einheiten mehr auf der einen also auf
der Westseite des Flusses stünden was
hat das alles zu bedeuten für Russland
aber natürlich auch für die Ukraine muss
die Ukraine eventuell mit einer Falle
rechnen dort und wie groß sind in der
Tat die russischen Verluste über diese
und weitere Fragen wollen wir heute
sprechen mit dem Militärexperten Gustav
kressel vom European Council und vor
relations und später auch mit unserem
ZDF Reporter daran Hassan sadi der steht
nämlich in der Ukraine eure Fragen und
Kommentare wie immer gerne per Mail oder
über die Social Media Kanäle an uns
zunächst aber zu unserem ersten Gast
Gustav Ressel schon öfter bei uns in der
Sendung gewesen einen schönen guten
Abend nach Berlin hallo guten Abend
also der russische Abzug aus herson
schändliche Niederlage zusammen so sehen
und zu sagen es die einen in Moskau nein
sagen die anderen eine taktische
richtige Entscheidung und sinnvolle
Umgruppierung der Gruppen wie sehen sie
diese Entwicklung also aus rein
militärischer Perspektive macht der
Abzug aus kessern absolut Zähnen die
russischen Kräfte hatten nicht die
Stärke irgendwie weiter anzugreifen die
Front war enorm exponiert und vor allen
Dingen waren dort wichtige Einheiten vor
allen Dingen falsche mega eingesetzt das
waren 30.000 Großteil des Berufssoldaten
Zeitsoldaten das ist jetzt in Zeiten
einer mobil machen wo die russische
Armee zwar enorm viele neue Leute junge
18-Jährige Buben einberuft und eine eine
Waffe umhängt enorm wichtig weil diese
Leute müssen ja doch irgendwie ein
geführt werden die brauchen Kommandanten
die brauchen Spezialisten und diese
Leute sind alle knapp das heißt
militärisch natürlich ist der Abzug
sinnvoll und auch schon der Vorgänger
des oberkommandeurs in der Ukraine des
der russischen Kräfte hat den auch schon
gefordert vor über einem Monat Putin hat
den verneint wo wir zur politischen
Situation kommen natürlich für Putin ist
es ein Prestigeverlust und eine eine
politische schwere Niederlage aber Putin
rechnet ja auch mit einem langen Krieg
nicht mit etwas was schnell vorbeigeht
oder was er im kurzen gewinnen kann und
deshalb muss er hier dann auch auf die
auf den Rad seiner militärischen
Fachkräfte hören ja vielen Dank schon
mal für diese erste Einschätzung wie
genau die Situation in herson heute
aussieht was dort heute passierte
darüber gibt uns jetzt meine Kollegin
Christa Kristina pardon gründgen noch
mal ein Bild
sie jubeln schwenken ukrainische Fahnen
und fallen den ankommenden Soldaten
begeistert in die Arme der Triumph in
reson wird gefeiert auch in den sozialen
Medien die Skepsis der vergangenen Tage
ob die Russen tatsächlich aus der Stadt
und der Region abziehen war ich der
Euphorie
[Applaus]
diese Bilder sollen zeigen wie einen
Teil der russischen Soldaten den Fluss
nipro überquerte zu Fuß über eine
schwimmende Behelfsbrücke der Abzug sei
abgeschlossen so das russische
Verteidigungsministerium
nicht ein einziges Teil militärischer
Ausrüstung wurde zurückgelassen alle
russischen Soldaten haben den Fluss
überquert
doch bei aller Freude Gerüchte das
womöglich doch bis zu mehrere tausend
Russen in Hessen zurückgeblieben sein
bereiten auch ukrainischen offiziellen
Sorge
viele Russen konnten den den nipro nicht
überqueren sie werfen ihre Uniformen weg
ziehen Sie die Kleidung an und versuchen
sich zu verstecken sie werden
Provokationen in reschon vorbereiten es
gibt noch viel zu tun
die Behelfsbrücke über den Fluss liegt
heute in Trümmern genau wie die schon
länger beschädigte große Brücke daneben
ein weiteres Symbol für einen der
größten Rückschläge für Russland seit
Beginn des Krieges
Herr Kessel wir gehen gleich noch mal
genauer auf die Situation in herson ein
aber noch mal die übergeordnete Frage
vorneweg die Rückeroberung durch die
ukrainischen Truppen welche Bedeutung
militärisch aber auch politisch
symbolisch hat diese ihrer Meinung nach
also für die Ukraine ist es einmal
militärisch ein ein wichtiger Sieg weil
sie durch diesen diese Verkürzung des
frontabschnitts durch das Erreichen des
nährproteine sehr einfach zu
verteidigende Linie ist sich in etwa
sieben Brigaden einspart an Kräften und
diese rauslösen kann und in dem Osten
der Ukraine weiter einsetzen kann das
einmal das eine das zweite ist natürlich
ein ein moralischer ein moralischer Sieg
und ein
Motivationsschub den sie dadurch
bekommen hat das ist eine Hauptstadt
eines oblasts der annektiert wurde man
hatte sie wieder zurückbekommen das ist
ein Carson ist eine große Stadt man hat
in mehrere wieder erreicht die
wichtigste Binnenwasserstraße der
Ukraine wir haben auch keine Nachricht
dass novakua also diesen großen
Wasserkraftwerk aber irgendwas passiert
ist auf diesem Wege also ein Haufen
Unsicherheiten die jetzt mal wie ein
Stein natürlich von der Seele der Leute
fallen dass das erreicht wurde aber
damit ist natürlich der Krieg auch noch
lange nicht zu Ende das ist die die
zweite Nachricht und es konnten sich
zumindest gewisse Teile oder erhebliche
Teile der russischen Streitkraft doch
auch über den nebrot zurückziehen und
gegen die wird man auch einem anderen
Tage wieder kämpfen müssen tja wir haben
es gerade im Film auch gesehen und die
Frage geht auch in die Richtung die
Stefan es uns stellt über Youtube welche
Logik steckt hinter der Aussage die
Russen könnten in Zivilkleidung die
Stadt verteidigen also es wurde ja auch
gerade im Beitrag gesagt das sind wohl
einige Russen einige tausend sogar in
der Stadt geblieben und die könnten
natürlich dann auch Angriffe in Zukunft
für üben auf die dann wieder
einrückenden Ukrainer wie sehen Sie das
also das sind solche Aktionen ist es
Verwirrung zu stiften man tritt den
Zivil auf schießt Soldaten an die können
den Angriff nicht genau zuordnen da sich
der Angreifer dann auch in
Zivilverwaltung bewegt kann man ihn dann
von den normalen Zivilisten auch nicht
gut unterscheiden und das Ziel dieser
solche Aktionen wäre es sozusagen ein
Massaker an Zivilbevölkerung zu
provozieren übertriebene
Abwehrreaktionen zu provozieren und so
das Vertrauen der der Ukrainer in die
ukrainische Armee zu erschüttern
ob das jetzt mit Erfolg durchgeführt
werden kann ist fraglich es gab am
Nachmittag
Bild und Videoaufnahmen die in sozialen
Netzwerken in der Ukraine geteilt worden
von russischen Soldaten in zivilgewand
mit mit Bewaffnung allerdings soweit ich
weiß sind deren Stellungen bekannt und
das wurde eben dann auch der Armee
mitgeteilt das heißt man weiß wo sich
diese Kräfte aufhalten und diese Kräfte
die stehen ja jetzt vor der Entscheidung
entweder sie ziehen das durch aber das
ist sicherer Tod oder sie ergeben sich
und sie ihr Leben zumindest in
Kriegsgefangenschaft weiter das heißt
ich würde jetzt nicht sehr viel drauf
wetten dass diese Kräfte wirklich diese
Befehle so wie so wie angedacht
ausführen werden
schauen wir noch mal auf die Situation
in Person statt da haben wir auch eine
Karte vorbereitet da war jetzt in den
letzten Tagen wenn man sich das mal
anschaut auch geographisch viel von
Flussufern die Rede es geht um den nipro
vielleicht können sie uns da auch noch
mal gerade erläutern
Herr gressel wie sich das da genau
verhält wer befindet sich der aktuell wo
und inwieweit ist es wichtig wenn man
jetzt diesen Fluss da noch
berücksichtigt ja also der Fluss nepto
ist wie gesagt die größte
Binnenwasserstraße in in der Ukraine ist
ein riesenfluss mehrere Kilometer breit
und es südlich und
Umkehr so nach oben vor allen Dingen am
südhofer gibt es sehr große
aullandschaften Sumpflandschaften
schwämmland und dann ein großes Delta
all dieses Land kann ich im Grunde mit
dem Panzer nicht durchfahren das ist
unpassierbar Jenseits die der großen
Brücken und eben das Wasserkraft zwar
ist in novakova habe ich im Grunde keine
tragfähigen oder kaum tragfähige Gänge
das heißt ich kann diesen diesen Fluss
auch gut sperren wenn ich am Ufer Sitze
bis da bis man damit Schiffen
herüberfährt oder einen einen Sturm
Angriff mit pionierbooten fahren würden
da ist man relativ leichtes Ziel das
heißt er ist einfach zu verteidigen es
ist auch mit inklusive des schwemmlandes
ein sehr sehr breiter Gürtel der der
ebenso von der Ausdehnung so groß ist
dass man zumindest mit Granatwerfern
oder mit den meisten Granatwerfern auch
nicht drüber schießen kann und die
ukrainische Seite hat jetzt das
nördliche
Ufer oder das westliche Ufer vollständig
unter ihrer Kontrolle das heißt auf
diesem Ufer gibt es keine
keine russischen Streitkräfte die noch
zumindest noch die noch Zusammenhängen
kämpfen können und damit sozusagen hat
man hier diese sichere Linie jetzt mal
eingenommen
wie verhält es sich denn jetzt mit den
Brücken die über den Fluss verlaufen
offenbar sind die inzwischen ja nun auch
alle oder zumindest größtenteils
zerstört erst ja von der Ukraine um den
Nachschub der Russen zu unterbinden
jetzt von den Russen um die Ukraine dann
am Nachsetzen zu hindern welche Folgen
hat das jetzt dass die Brücken alle
nicht mehr intakt sind
also die Brücken sind seit langem schon
für schweres Gerät für Panzer für
munitionstransporter
unbasierbar oder waren unpassierbar
jetzt sind sie auch
faktisch gesprengt das heißt die Ukraine
kann über diese Brücken auch nicht den
Russen nachstoßen oder Richtung Grimm
hinunterstoßen für solche Angriffe
müsste man aus saporizische heraus
operieren und von dort nach nach
Südwesten stoßen ich glaube aber das ist
zurzeit auch nicht die Hauptsorge der
Ukraine weil natürlich auch ein Stoß
über so über eine Brücke mit so einer
mit seiner schmalen Verbindungslinie
natürlich ein sehr riskantes Unterfangen
wäre das stimmt aber natürlich können
die Russen jetzt auch nicht wieder
zurück also wenn die jetzt noch vorher
hätten in in herson auch in der Region
Herr Sonnen weitere Geländegewinne
wieder zu erzielen oder zurückzugewinnen
auch schwierig im Moment das geht auch
schwierig bzw nicht mehr man hat die die
entsprechenden Brücken man hat er den
knetros sehr schnell überschritten
dritten märz ist schon gefallen das war
zwar eine Zeit wo auf ukrainischer Seite
die mobil machen noch lange nicht
abgeschlossen war wo man sehr wenig
Kräfte hat wo aufgrund des schnellen
Vorstoßes gerade im Süden wo die Gegend
sehr flach ist Moment Panzern sehr weit
kommt wo es keine natürlichen
Hindernisse gibt für mechanisierte
Kräfte wo man sozusagen die die
unorganisiertheit und die das Chaos in
den ukrainischen Verteidigungsreihen
auch gut ausnutzen kann aber diese
einfache Zeit ist ja schon lange dahin
und wenn man dieses Ufer noch einmal
einnehmen will dann wird es erheblich
mehr an Verlusten Kosten und
wahrscheinlich wird sich an diesem
Frontabschnitt auch wenig bis keine
große Schlacht mehr abspielen die eine
russische südoffensive Richtung Odessa
ist jetzt sehr sehr schwer bis unmöglich
hoher fragt uns über Youtube wie
realistisch wahrscheinlich ist es den
kartofka-damm zu sprengen große Verluste
wären sicher allerdings ja dann auch auf
beiden Seiten
soweit ich es jetzt auf Karten gesehen
habe
sind die ukrainischen Streitkräfte dort
schon angekommen das heißt wenn man den
sprengen wollte dann hätte man es tun
müssen also es gibt aus aus umliegenden
Dörfern des Tams schon Bestätigungen das
ukrainische Soldaten dort sind und ich
ich denke sie sind auch schon am Damm
die Brücke die über den Damm geht die
ist beschädigt bzw gesprengt aber in der
Staumauer selbst gibt es noch keine
keine Beschädigung ich denke auch dass
russischerseits selbst wenn man ihn zur
Sprengung vorbereitet hat man sich das
genau überlegen wird weil ja der Kanal
zur Wasserversorgung der Krim aus dem
Staudamm selbst abgezweigt wird und wenn
man die Staumauer sprengt und der
wasserpegelt dann sinkt würde man die
Wasserversorgung der Krim damit auch
gefährden das heißt ich denke die
Sprengung dieses damals hätte hätten die
russischen Streitkräfte nur dann
vorgenommen wenn die Lage
Umkehr schon so brenzlig gewesen wäre
dass sie ihre Evakuierung auch nicht
abgeschlossen hätten bzw wenn die
Ukrainer wenn es den Ukraine gelungen
wäre über den Fluss selber drüber zu
stoßen ja okay und noch mal abschließend
jetzt zu diesem sozusagen Themenkomplex
Herr Sonne und den heutigen
Entwicklungen wie ist jetzt die aktuelle
Lage sozusagen und auch für die nächsten
Tage einzuschätzen die Russen haben sich
jetzt verschanzt auf der anderen Seite
des Flusses wird das jetzt da ein
wochenlanger Stellungskrieg werden oder
wie glauben sie wird das sich jetzt
entwickeln die Fortsetzung von
Artillerie Duellen über den Fluss die
die ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit vor
allen Dingen mit raketenartillerie die
weiter schießt sonst denke ich dass
jetzt die Ukraine zuerst mal die die
Gegend säubern das heißt die Häuser
durchsuchen untersuchen ob noch irgendwo
verbliebene versprengte russische Kräfte
zugegen sind und dann werden sie sich
mit mit Infanterie mit territial
Verteidigung zu Verteidigung einrichten
dass sie vor allen Dingen die starken
Ufer und die mechanisierten Kräfte die
schweren Kräfte dann wahrscheinlich
gegen dann gegen den in den Don was
verlegen es ist sonst sozusagen die
irgendwo in den Fluss einmal erreicht
war auf dieser Front ja auch nicht nicht
mehr viel groß zu holen
Fliegerabwehr drohnenabwehr das wird
weiterhin ein Thema bleiben also neben
den artillerie-auangriffen auf kerson
ist natürlich damit zu rechnen dass
jetzt Person auch ziel dieser iranischen
Drohnen bzw möglicher Marschflugkörper
wird sowie Nikolai das eine Stadt die
etwa 70 km nordwestlich von von careson
liegt ja auch in den vergangenen Monaten
schwere Treffer einstecken hat müssen
Wasserversorgung Stromversorgung Nicolai
fuhren wurden zerstört
warnen rise schreibt uns über Youtube
Russland war die zweitgrößte Armee in
der Welt jetzt ist sie die zweitgrößte
Armee in der Ukraine lassen wir jetzt
einfach mal so stehen vielen Dank für
den Moment Gustav Gressl wir sprechen
gleich weiter wollen aber vorher noch
meinen Kollegen Dara Hassan ZD mit in
die Runde holen der uns aktuell aus der
Ukraine genauer einer Großstadt im Süden
zugeschaltet ist und von dort für uns
berichtet guten Abend daran
hallo daher gibt es sowas wie Euphorie
in der Ukraine angesichts der
Rückeroberung von herson oder wie
würdest du die Stimmung dort beschreiben
ja also die Party wenn ich das mal so
sagen darf die findet heute natürlich in
Hass und statt hier wo wir jetzt sind
war bis eben als Herr kressel noch
sprach Luft Alarm der wurde hier die
Entwarnung kam erst eben und da geht
natürlich trotzdem viele Leute nicht auf
die Straße um zu feiern ich habe bei
vielen Menschen enorme Genugtuung
festgestellt sie haben lange jetzt
gewartet es hat sich ja angekündigt die
ganze
Großoffensive auf reison hat sich ja
seit Juli hingezogen und deswegen war in
den letzten Tagen so eine gewisse
Unsicherheit da ob das jetzt auch
wirklich kommt dieses lange ersehnte
Ereignis und für die Leute die Verwandte
und Freunde in herson und haben ist das
natürlich ein historischer Tag ein Tag
in denen ihre sie ihre Gefühle kaum im
Zaum halten werden öffentliche Partys
dafür ist die Stimmung hier einfach auch
zu ernst die Luftangriffe gehen weiter
die Heizungs die Gasversorgung in vielen
Bereichen ist nicht gewährleistet Strom
fällt oft aus das ganze Netz ist am
Rande und das ist natürlich nicht
verschwunden durch die Rückeroberung
durch Herzen klar also bedrückende
Gesamtsituation nach wie vor du hast in
den letzten Tagen auch die ukrainischen
Soldaten an der Frontlinie erlebt welche
Eindrücke konntest du da sammeln wie ist
die Moral der ukrainischen Truppe
die dürfte jetzt überragend sein wir
hatten mit einzelnen Soldaten gesprochen
mit den niederen Rängen und das war die
Ungeduld schon groß sie waren sich
sicher dass sie weil sie ja schon so
wenige Kilometer
vor dem Stadtgebiet vor den Stadtgrenzen
von den Außenbereichen standen speziell
die Soldaten die bei Nikolajew
stationiert waren dass sie das schnell
erobern könnten aber Sie bekommen halt
nicht den Befehl oder sie bekamen ihn
nicht und die Offiziere wiederum haben
gesagt diese Zurückhaltung rettet
eigentlich jeden Tag leben und auf lange
Sicht ist das militärisch für die
russische Seite nicht zu halten und sie
haben heutigen Tag recht bekommen
ja also vielleicht auch noch mal dazu
den Hintergründen warum das Tempo eher
langsam aus Vorsicht nämlich an
das war auf jeden Fall Vorsicht und es
war halt hatte sehr viel auch mit den
modernen mit der modernen westlichen
Artillerie zu tun sie konnten ganz
gezielt Munitionsdepots und Kommando
stellte treffen und dadurch war die
Versorgung von bis zu 30.000 russischen
Soldaten auf der anderen Seite des
Flusses nicht mehr möglich vor allem
nachdem sie auch die großen Brücken
getroffen hatten du hast gerade schon
ein bisschen beschrieben wie die
Situation im Land ist wie groß sind die
Zerstörungen die du auch gerade in
Person in der Region gesehen hast und
wie gehen die wie gehen die Ukraine und
die Ukraine damit um
wir waren heute den ganzen Tag in der
Region ferson unterwegs im Umland was
zugänglich war und es also selbst die
Ortschaften die nicht völlig zerstört
sind haben enorme Schäden es gibt Dörfer
die sind durch die wurde die Frontlinie
ist quasi über sie drüber gerollt sie
waren die Frontlinie da steht ist kein
Haus mehr bewohnbar wir haben heute mit
Handwerkern gesprochen der ein Dach
notdürftig repariert haben die haben
gesagt wir reparieren wirklich jetzt
noch improvisat wir improvisieren weil
wir nicht wissen ob von der anderen
Seite nur weiterhin Artillerie
geschossen werden kann und dann wäre
alles umsonst wenn wir das jetzt wieder
richtig langfristig aufbauen würden da
fehlt also noch die Sicherheit und der
sichere Sieg das jetzt alles sicher sei
so ist die Lage dort in keiner Weise
aber so ein grundoptimismus ist
vorhanden also man glaubt nach wie vor
daran dass man die komplette Ukraine
zurückerobern kann
bei ganz vielen Menschen ist es so und
ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt
weitergehen es geht gar nicht und um
glaube das ist das festgesetzte Ziel was
Sie erreichen wollen selbst wenn sie
scheitern wollen würden und sie die
härteste Phase des Krieges war ja am
Anfang und wenn man sich doch mal vor
Augen führt wie nah die russischen
Truppen in welcher Übermacht sie
forkiert standen dann hat sich jetzt
natürlich die Situation trotz der
schwierigen Versorgungslage und des
Stromnetzes deutlich verbessert für die
gesamtexistenz des Staates die seeblock
Karte ist aufgelöst die moskreis
gesunken real soll es zurückerobert
Traggriff ist zurückerobert also die
Gesamtlage ist auch da findet man schon
auch Gründe für Optimismus klar es gab
auf jeden Fall Teil Erfolge vielleicht
noch mal auch kurz über ein paar Worte
über den Gegner welche Informationen
oder Schilderungen hast du über die
russischen Truppen bekommen woran liegt
es vielleicht auch dass diese sich jetzt
zurückziehen mussten was hört man über
die Aufstellung die Motivation der
russischen Truppen vielleicht auch über
die Zusammensetzung man hört auch von
vielen jungen unerfahrenen
Kriegsteilnehmern die halt eben da an
die Front geschickt worden sind
teilweise wohl auch einfach verheizt
worden sind was sind deine Erkenntnisse
oder was sagt man vielleicht auch auf
Seiten der der Ukraine über die Gegner
wie denkt man über die
gibt es natürlich verschiedene
Levels sag ich mal es gibt den einen
Löffel wo die Ukraine wirklich
Weltklasse sind es ist die Ironie es ist
der Witz das ist die Karikatur und da
ist ja auch immer ein Funken Wahrheit
drin und von Traktoren die die Moskwa am
Grund des schwarzen Meers weggezogen
haben bis zu Briefmarken wird natürlich
der Gegner verhöhnt andererseits weiß
man um die Stärke man ist sich auch
bewusst dass die Anzahl von von Soldaten
auf der russischen Seite viel viel höher
ist und natürlich je länger so ein Krieg
geht umso weniger kann auf lange Sicht
auf Jahre gesehen die ukrainische Armee
ihre eigenen Soldaten die gefallen sind
ersetzen
übernimmt denn Gegner auf die Schippe
einerseits aber andererseits ist die
ernster ist da immer der Ernst der Lage
drin zu spüren und es ist kein keine
Naivität Sie wissen dass Sie mit
jemandem zu tun haben der eine Armee die
schrecklich gebracht hat den Botschaft
die von nichts zurückschreckt die
Luftangriffe sind strategisch grausam
treffen sehr viel von der
Zivilbevölkerung und trotzdem hat man
ich selber habe es auch gesehen liegen
gelassene
Lebensmittelrationen die
Jahrzehnte zurückdatiert waren von der
russischen Armee also die
Versorgungslage ist wirklich nicht gut
aus der Ukraine und eben auch aus dem
Frontgebiet waren das von Dara Hassan CD
vielen Dank und ich hoffe sehr dass ihr
vor weiteren Alarmen dann heute
zumindest mal verschont bleibt pass auf
Dich auf vielen Dank
ja ich hoffe er hat es gehört auf
Wiedersehen wir sprechen weiter mit
Gustav gressel und wir kommen gleich
noch mal zum Thema herson zurück aber
vielleicht vorher auch weil wir gerade
insgesamt über die Situation in der
Ukraine und auch über Russland
gesprochen haben Herr Gassel was wissen
Sie über Verluste man hat jetzt vor
wenigen Tagen gehört Angaben des
US-Militärs je 100.000 Wohlgefallen oder
zumindest außer Gefecht gesetzte ich sie
können das besser beschreiben als ich
wie ist da ihr Erkenntnisstand ja es
gibt von beiden Seiten nur Schätzungen
man kann sich dem in etwa annähern indem
man schaut wie viel Gerät wurde zerstört
was ist nachweislich zerstört und wie
stark liegen diese Schätzungen
normalerweise daneben
also auf der russischen Seite würde ich
würde ich etwas höher gehen so um die
120.000 Mann die nicht mehr im Krieg
teilnehmen können weil sie entweder tot
sind oder schwer verwundet auf der
ukrainischen Seite etwa 100.000 wenn ich
auch 120.000 waren allerdings ist sie
Zusammensetzung anders in Russland hat
man ein Verhältnis von Toten zu
schwer verwundeten etwa von 1 zu 2 in
der Ukraine hat man eins zu vier eins zu
fünf die ukrainische Zahnkette das heißt
die die Kette an Fahrzeugen und an
Einrichtungen die verwundete Bergen
versorgen einem Krankenhaus einer
Operation zuführen die läuft viel besser
als auf der russischen Seite die
ukrainischen Soldaten nehmen ihre ihre
angeschlossenen in ihre verwundeten
Kameraden auch immer mit während auf der
russischen Seite die oft zurückgelassen
werden und deshalb ist die
Überlebenschance für einen schwer
verwundeten ukrainischen Soldaten
ungemein höher als russischen
verstehe sind das zahlen wenn man jetzt
noch mal über die die Verluste und auch
über die Toten sprechen die die Putin so
ohne weiteres seiner Bevölkerung jetzt
über längere Zeit wird zumuten können
das ist ja auch eben unser Thema heute
wie schwer wie die Niederlage in
tresonne aber auch die Gesamtsituation
also wie lange kommt er damit mit dieser
Taktik und mit diesen hohen
Verlustzahlen durch Russland ist ein
Polizeistaat da ist die Möglichkeit
Designs und Protest zu äußern auch im
Vergleich zum Russland der 90er Jahre
oder dem Tschetschenienkrieg
mittlerweile so stark eingeschränkt dass
das einfach Kraft der Repression
nicht zum innenpolitischen Thema gemacht
wird es wird Russland natürlich
langfristig treffen man muss ja auch
sehen dass gerade unter dem mobil
gemacht den Leuten die jetzt zwangsweise
in die Armee eingezogen werden viele
junge Leute sind die noch vor ihrem
Familienleben sind die noch vorher im
Berufsleben sind die die zukünftige
russische Wirtschaft die zukünftige russ
diese Gesellschaft mitbestimmen oder mit
mittragen hätten sollen oder können bei
den alten freiwilligen das waren oft
ausgediente Polizisten ausgediente
Armeeangehörige die integriert man in
kein Wirtschaftsleben mehr aber jetzt
wird im Grunde die Axt die demografische
Axt ganz unten angesetzt und das bei
einer ohnehin schon stark überalterten
Gesellschaft das ohnehin schon in einer
Gesellschaft die Arbeitskräfte Mangel
hat ganz dramatisch also die
langfristigen ökonomischen Kosten ganz
egal wie sich Putins Regime
weiterentwickelt für diesen Krieg sind
enorm
Mathe fragt uns über Youtube wäre jetzt
nicht wo die Russen sich zurückziehen
auch von deutscher Seite offensiv
Friedensverhandlungen zu fordern
also auf der russischen Seite schaut die
die Lage so aus dass man zurzeit zwar
Verhandlungen haben will aber nicht um
Frieden wie ich vorher schon gesagt habe
es läuft die mobil machen man generiert
neue Kräfte die der Großteil dieser
Kräfte ist ja noch in Russland da werden
neue Einheiten neue Bataillonen neue
Brigaden formiert und die sollen dann in
den nächsten Wochen und Monaten an die
Front ich würde auch etwas darauf tippen
dass das nicht die letzte Welle der
mobil machen ist sondern dass da mehr
kommt 300.000 die man jetzt mobil
gemacht hat reichen im Grunde für
Russland nicht aus um die Initiative
wieder zu gewinnen wieder offensivfähig
zu werden und die Rhetorik in Russland
in Moskau geht er immer noch in diese
Richtung
dafür braucht man aber Zeit und das
sozusagen Beste aus russischer Sicht
wäre wenn man Friedensverhandlungen
führen würde oder Waffen
stillstandsverhandlungen führen würde
die dann die frontstabilisieren die
einen um die Mühen diese Front in einer
Schwäche Phase zu verteidigen ersparen
und dann im März Februar wenn man wieder
stark genug ist um anzugreifen zu können
dann kündigt man diese Verhandlungen
dann sagt man die Ukraine hat sich an
XYZ nicht gehalten jetzt ist sozusagen
alles wieder hinfällig und dann greift
man wieder an
so leicht darf man ihnen auch nicht
machen das wäre jetzt etwas kurzsichtig
da muss man schon schauen in welchem
Zustand
ist Russland in welchem mit welchem mit
welchen verhandlungspunkten gehen die
Delegationen in die Gespräche hinein und
ist das sinnvoll oder nicht zur Zeit ist
es eben nur taktisches hinhalten leider
inwieweit wird oder könnte die
Rückeroberung ja sonst den weiteren
Kriegsverlauf beeinflussen also
zumindest mal im Süden der Ukraine
Vormarsch auf Odessa wäre vielleicht ein
Stichwort und das andere wäre vielleicht
auch sozusagen Angriffe die jetzt wieder
möglich scheinen auf die Krim durch die
Ukraine weil man jetzt ja doch wieder in
Schlagdistanz zumindest mit wenn ich das
richtig verstehe der Langstrecken
Artillerie wäre
ja die ukrainische Langstrecken
Artillerie also die heimatsysteme können
jetzt vor allen Dingen wichtige
Nachschublinien die aus der Krim heraus
gehen unter Beschuss nehmen allerdings
nur wenn dort die POS sind wenn dort
stationäre Einrichtungen sind weil weil
man natürlich mit der Langstrecken
Artillerie jetzt keine fahrenden
Fahrzeuge trifft oder keine fahrenden
Züge aber man kann Brücken treffen
man kann
Kommandostellen Depots entlang dieses
Weges treffen und das wird für Russland
schmerzlich was den Angriff auf die
krim- oder Richtung Creme angeht ist
natürlich jetzt auf der ukrainischen
Seite der nebremenweg also da ist es
einfacher für die für den Nachschub für
das aus der Sicht des Überwinden von
einem geländerinnen ist wenn man aus
saporisische Richtung Süden
durchstößt Richtung asowsches Meer die
russische Front 2 teilt und dann
versucht Richtung Westen einzuschränken
das wäre aber eine sehr sehr große
Operation dazu braucht man enorm viele
Kräfte auch dann um die Flanke zu decken
die man hier auf beiden Seiten aufmacht
dazu bräuchte die Ukraine im Grunde mehr
vor allen Dingen mehr gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge mehr Schützenpanzer auch mehr
Kampfpanzer und an an dem Material an
der Munition das ist zurzeit der größte
Engpass aus der russischen Seite ist
natürlich trotz dieser Niederlage muss
man mal schauen wie viel Kräfte hat man
jetzt wirklich evakuiert diese Kräfte
diese Berufssoldaten werden ja dann in
der weiteren im weiteren Verlauf des
Krieges eingebaut in die neue mobil
gemacht und Kräfte sollen diesen
Erfahrungen Rückhalt bilden und da kann
man eine nächste mobilisierungswelle mit
diesen Kräften als Kommandanten und
Spezialkräften durchaus durchführen in
dem Sinn ist der der Rückzug taktisch
schmerzlich wenn man den aber
hinbekommen hat und ich denke ja dieser
Rückzug der läuft nicht erst seit
gestern gestern hat man es nur zugegeben
dass man sich mit diesen Kräften
zurückzieht für das eigene Publikum der
läuft ja schon länger
das hier einiges rausgekommen ist und
das
wiederum erhält die Durchhaltefähigkeit
der russischen Armee für den Krieg der
sich wahrscheinlich noch bis über das
nächste Jahr Strecken wird also das
heißt auch ein weiteres vorrücken dann
doch auf Odessa auf andere Ziele im
Süden ist nicht ausgeschlossen ich
glaube nicht dass die nächste russische
Offensive wenn sie wieder diese Stärke
haben die sie haben wollen und die sie
brauchen über den Süden geht es gibt
wieder ein hochfahren der Übungen in
Belarus auch hier fließen russische
Kräfte ein um die
personalschwache belarussische Armee
aufzuproppen wir werden auch es gibt
wieder Verlegungen von Kräften an die
Nordgrenze an die Grenze zuchaki
hier tut sich militärisch auf der
russischen Seite weit mehr als im Süden
ich glaube diese dieser südkorridor das
war der Plan dieses Kriegsjahres der ist
darin gescheitert dass die Ukraine eben
im Süden große Wasserhindernisse hat der
hat mir privat nicht das einzige der Bug
wäre diese große Fluss wo alle nur alle
paar hundert Kilometer eine Brücke über
den Fluss ist und der so breit ist dass
ein wirkmächtiges Gelände Hindernis
darstellt also diese diese südoffensive
hat man sich leichter geplant also dann
wirklich umzusetzen war vor allen Dingen
weil der ukrainische Widerstand dann
auch stark ist im Norden ist es mit dem
Gelände einfacher einzudringen aus dem
russischen und belarussischen zumindest
aus dem russischen theaterum bei Belarus
ist die Grenze auch durch die
Präparation für etwas schwierig aber ich
denke dass für das nächste Kriegsjahr
Russland sich eher den Norden vornehmen
wird aber da kann man mal sehen wie auch
im 21 Jahrhundert sozusagen die
geografischen Gegebenheiten doch ganz
entscheidend sind für die Kriegsführung
Roland Karl fragt uns über Youtube wie
wirkt sich der russische
Materialverlust aus jetzt müsste man
natürlich genau wissen wie hoch ist
dieser die Frage dahinter vielleicht
auch nach den Reserven wie schätzen Sie
die ein wie viel Material hat Putin hat
Moskau in der Hinterhand
Material ist oder wird langsam auch auf
der russischen Seite zum Problem also
nicht nur auf der ukrainischen sondern
auf der russischen das bezieht sich vor
allen Dingen auf die Artillerie für
viele der gezogenen Artilleriegeschütze
die heute durch Russland eingesetzt
werden gibt es ja die die
Produktionsmaschine nicht mehr die hat
man ich denke an Nordkorea verkauft und
dann an anderen Entwicklungsländer
das Problem ist jetzt nach einer nach
einer gewissen Schussanzahl leiern die
Rohre aus man muss sie man muss die
Rohre die Rohr Seele austauschen bzw das
Rohr komplett wechseln wenn es wenn es
zu ausgeschlossen ist und dafür braucht
man eigentlich die alten
Produktionsmaschinen und wenn man die
nicht mehr hat kommt man nicht mehr ran
an neuen Artilleriegeschützen wird sehr
wenig produziert dass da ist man nicht
dort wo man eigentlich sein will bei den
Kampfpanzern schaut ein bisschen besser
aus da hat man
Kampfpanzer die für den Export nach
Indien bestimmt waren requiriert da hat
man aus den Depots
Detail gemacht da ist man zumindest in
der Quantität
da wo man hin will die Qualität zum Teil
sind das ältere Stücke aus dem Depots
ist man nicht ganz da aber dass das
nimmt man dann hin die Frage Munition
wird auch spannend da ist die
pulverproduktion die
treibladungsproduktion der Engpass
da ist aber auch spannend viele der
alten Produktionsstätten hat man eben
wiederum an Nordkorea an andere Staaten
verkauft da will man jetzt sozusagen die
Produkte
zurückkaufen und im Falle Nordkorea muss
man auch sagen nordkorea war schon seit
den 90er Jahren eine große Drehscheibe
für für schwarzmarktgüter so hat
Russland
isolierten und unter Sanktionen
stehenden Staaten Rüstungsgüter verkauft
vor allen Dingen im Iran indem man sie
nach Nordkorea geliefert hat dort wurden
sie umlackiert nordkoreanisch bezeichnet
und gingen dann an den exportkunden und
das kann man ja auch umgekehrt spielen
nicht nur der ran sondern auch Nordkorea
kann ja auch und tun auch einkaufen bzw
bekommen auch Munition aus anderen
Staaten in Nordkorea werden wir diese
Munition wieder nordkoreanisch und geht
dann nach Russland weiter
in dem Sinn
befürchte ich da dass die
Durchhaltefähigkeit der russischen Armee
war zumindest was die einfache Munition
also Artillerie
[Musik]
feldraketenwerfer panzermunition angeht
doch doch noch lange nicht das Ende der
Fahnenstange erreicht also erheblicher
Reserven Yuno fragt uns über Youtube wie
stark schätzen Sie die noch vorhandenen
Kräfte der verbleibenden russischen
Truppen ein im Verhältnis zu den
ukrainischen gibt es da zahlen die sie
da parat haben wie ist das Verhältnis es
ist leider sehr schwer abzuschätzen weil
die Ukraine sehr sehr bedeckt sind was
ihre jetziges Struktur angeht in der
Ukraine stehen etwa 700.000 Männer und
Frauen in Uniform dass sie natürlich
jetzt alles nicht Kampfverbände die im
Feld stehen Kampfverbände im Fels immer
bei etwa 400.000 Mann
auf der russischen Seite sind wir etwa
jetzt wieder bei den 190.000 wie es zu
Kriegsbeginn war durch das Einfließen
von etwa 50.000 mobil gemachten die
jetzt kommen und weitere 250.000 werden
sozusagen in unmittelbarer nächster Zeit
noch dazu stoßen
das klingt jetzt natürlich nach einer
großen Überlegenheit für die Ukraine das
Problem der Ukraine ist dass die
russische Seite immer noch einen einen
Vorteil an artelerieren kampfpan sondern
schweren Gerät an technischen Gerät hat
die die Kräne nicht der die Ukraine sind
großteils leichte Infanterie mit der
leichten Infanterie kann ich natürlich
im infanteriegelände in Ortschaften in
Sumpf im Waldgebieten gut kämpfen aber
im offenen Gelände im panzergelände habe
ich natürlich ein Problem dass ich freie
Flächen nicht überwinden kann ohne
gepanzertes Fahrzeug dass ich den
Panzern im Angriff nicht so folgen kann
wenn ich ungepanzertes Radfahrzeug habe
das sind die Hauptprobleme die die
Ukraine haben man sieht es ja auch etwa
Munitionsverbrauch die russische Armee
verschießt immer noch etwa 20.000
Artilleriegranaten pro Tag die Ukraine
und können mit etwa 4 bis 5.000 pro Tag
Antworten die die munitions Knappheit
ist auf der ukrainischen Seite ein
enormes Problem und die gilt ja nicht
nur für Artilleriemunition wo das
Problem bekannt ist sondern eigentlich
für alle munitionsklassen vor allen
Dingen für östliches Gerät Kampf waren
sehr Schützenpanzer inklusive
Fliegerabwehr ist auch ein Riesenproblem
man ist halt einfach schon neun Monate
im Krieg und die eigene Munitionslager
bzw die der befreundeten Nachbarstaaten
Polen Slowakei Tschechien Bulgarien
Rumänien waren nicht auf so einen Krieg
in dieser Länge und in dieser Dimension
vorbereitet dass man hier viel Munition
hätte die man noch geben kann geben
könnte ja das beantwortet fast schon
auch die nächste Frage die wir jetzt
gewesen nach der Takt die offenbar ja in
herson erfolgreich war dass man eben vor
allem auch die russischen
Versorgungslinien abschneiden konnte
durch eben doch auch recht lang
anhaltenden Artilleriebeschuss man fragt
sich ob man das dann nicht in anderen
Regionen des Landes auch machen könnte
aber da kommt dann eben auch für die die
Munition denke ich ins Spiel die
Munition und die Geographie des
Abschneiden der nachschlupfwege war hier
besonders einfach weil eben jeder
Nachschub irgendwie über den Fluss muss
und da ist natürlich der praktische Weg
die Brücke und die die zwei Brücken die
über den über den kniepro geführt dann
die wurden dann relativ bald zumindest
so unbrauchbar gemacht dass man nicht
nur mit dem Fahrzeug drüber führen kann
weil sie statisch so instabil waren und
damit mussten die Russen alle Nachschub
mit dem Boot über den Fluss führen und
das bringt eine gewisse Statik in den in
den Nachschub ich muss ja mit dem LKW
zum Ufer fahren am Ufer liegt das Brot
verankert dann lade ich das in je
nachdem wie groß der Frachter ist oder
das Boot eben ein paar Minuten bis
Stunden in dieses Boot hinein dann fahre
ich über den Fluss dort muss ich das
Boot wieder festmachen alle Munition
ausladen und in LKWs reinladen das ist
uns das Boot kann er nicht im Kreis
fahren irgendwie das ist ein statisches
Ziel dem Moment wo die Ukraine weiß dass
zu diesem Zeitpunkt an dieser Stelle und
da gibt es wenige Stellen wo man anlegen
kann
die Hafenanlagen und Case sind ja alle
bekannt in dem Moment wo man weiß wo
jetzt ein Boot anlegt kann man dann
natürlich mit der Artillerie
reinschießen das ist im offenen Land ist
das schwieriger weil da LKW kann ein
Bewegung bleiben und solange im
Hinterland die Bewegung ist ist er für
die Artillerie natürlich kein Ziel da
muss ich dann erst mühsam die
Umschlagplätze ausfindig machen wo
Munition von der Eisenbahn abgeladen
wird auf die LKWs geladen wird wo bei
den LKWs von von Bataillon auf Brigade
und so weiter umgeschlagen wird die kann
ich dann treffen aber die sind natürlich
weit mobiler und immer auch ein bisschen
kleiner als diese großen umladeplätze wo
die Schiffe anlegen und deshalb ist das
Abschneiden Munition das war dann in
Carson eben eine eine gute Wahl diese
diese Kräfte dort zu fixieren und
auszuhungern verstehe wir kommen gleich
zum Ende Frank Farian schreibt uns noch
über Youtube liefert man iron Dome
Leopard 2 und andere nicht weil man
befürchtet dass sie erbeutet werden und
dann per Reverse Engineering die
Schwachstellen gesucht und gefunden
werden Reverse Engineering vielleicht
wenn Sie den Begriff noch mal kurz
erläutern
ist also kopieren so würde es im
Zivilmarkt auch kauft dass man sozusagen
einen ein Produkt einkauft sich das
anschaut und dann dasselbe dasselbe
nachbaut also beim beim Leopard 2 würde
ich sagen nein denn der Leopard 2 wurde
ja durch die Türkei zumindest in der
2:04 Variante in Syrien schon ein
gesetzt und viel dort Kräften in die
Hände die also Assad und spricht der
russischen Partei sozusagen
gebogen waren bzw auf der Seite kämpfen
das heißt der Leopard 2 und zumindest in
der A4 Variante ist Moskau schon ein
technisch bekanntes gerät man weiß was
da drin ist
irondrome wäre an und für sich dasselbe
weil der ja nicht an vorderster Front
Mitfahrt und der im Hinterland steht die
Chance dass der so erbeutet wird
es ist relativ gering ich halte das eher
für Ausreden die vorgeschoben wird bei
den Israelis geht die Sorge um das
Russland
den Iran stärker unterstützt im Iran
stärker in Syrien freie Hand lässt wenn
Israel Waffen liefert das Russland dann
auch direkt sozusagen Revanche Akte als
Revanche Akt etwa hisballer Hamas oder
andere Organisationen mit Waffen
beliefern könnte weshalb man das nicht
tut und beim Leopard 2 ist auch in
Deutschland erstens die innenpolitische
Ruhe in einer Partei und dann die die
braucht einige Leute im Kanzleramt vor
der Eskalation und vor sozusagen einem
zu schnellen Erfolg der Ukraine der der
also den Dingen den großen Atomkrieg
bringen könnte meiner Ansicht nach das
vordringliche Argument warum man das
nicht tut und das wird dann sozusagen
überkittet mit diesen ganzen mit diesen
ganzen scheinen Argumenten die alle
nicht sehr lange halten ist natürlich
auch insgesamt eine ziemlich klar
komplexe Gemengelage vielleicht noch mal
kurz zu herrson Moskau spricht davon
dass diese Region mitsamt ihre
Hauptstadt russisch sei klar ist ja auch
erst vor wenigen Wochen annektiert
worden es bleibe auch auf alle Zeiten
Russisch aber wie will man jetzt in
Moskau eigentlich diesen Anspruch
aufrechterhalten das wirkt ja jetzt
gerade ein bisschen absurd
das wirkt relativ absurd es wirkt auch
absurd dass man ja gesagt hat 87% der
Bürger von Carson haben sich für einen
Anschluss an Russland entschieden wenn
man sich die Bilder anschaut wie
ukrainische Soldaten als Befreier
gefeiert werden also da offenbart sich
ja die ganze Absurdität dieser Ansprüche
mit mit diesem ganzen
Anschluss Desaster hat ja auch Russland
die spezielle Stellung der Krim
untergraben die Creme wurde auch auf
ähnliche Wein ist er annektiert und bis
zu diesen großen Annexionen gab es ja im
Westen immer auch besorgen ist naja wir
können die Ukraine sollte doch nicht
etwas Schläge auf die auf der Krim
vornehmen denn das würde durch Russland
als das eigene Territorium betrachtet
das wäre eine höhere Eskalationsstufe
jetzt hat eigentlich die Ukraine hier an
diesem Gebieten vor exerziert dass das
alles Humbug ist und es hat damit auch
sozusagen die eigene russische Logik
oder die Logik die Russland uns
vorschreiben wollte anzuwenden in Bezug
auf die Krim untergraben da muss man
aber auch sagen Putin wurde vor diesem
Schritt von Scholz von macron von
Präsident beiden ja auch immer wieder
gewarnt und es wurde ihm auch immer
wieder erklärt macht das nicht gehe
nicht in die Annexion dass wird jede
Verhandlungslösung ungemein erschweren
und Putin hat das trotz aller dieser
Warnungen getan jetzt muss er halt auch
mit dem politischen Konsequenzen dieses
Handelns Leben es ist ja nicht so dass
wir ihn darum gebeten hätten in der Tat
nicht vielleicht noch mal zum Abschluss
unserer Ausgangsfrage um es nochmal auf
den Punkt zu bringen wir hatten gefragt
wie schwer wiegt diese Niederlage der
Rückzug aus herson für Moskau für Putin
ganz persönlich wie ist da ihre
Einschätzung was wird das jetzt bewirken
in Moskau wird er jetzt größer in Frage
gestellt
ich glaube nicht also es gibt einige
Unruhe und einige einige Hardliner haben
sich schon beschwert aber ihre
dementsprechenden Posts und Kommentare
sofort wieder gelöscht auch bei denen
kann natürlich der Hammerschlag der
Repression relativ schnell zulangen
das Russland glaube ich auch nicht oder
das jetzige Regime glaube ich auch nicht
dass zum gegenwärtigen Zeitpunkt so
instabil ist dass dass man eine
unmittelbare Bedrohung sieht wie gesagt
putin ist relativ zuversichtlich und der
hält noch an seinen maximalen Zielen
fest es hat sich da in der russischen
Rhetorik eigentlich nichts geändert er
glaubt nur dass dieser Sieg nur
langfristig zu erringen ist und nicht
mehr in wenigen Tagen oder Wochen
deshalb wird das leider Gottes noch ein
langer Krieg wenn sich diesbezüglich in
Russland etwas tut dann wird man das
auch an der Rhetorik der Propaganda
merken denn dann wird anfangen müssen
die Leute darauf vorzubereiten
etwas anderes als sie zu akzeptieren als
die totale Unterwerfung der Ukraine da
sind wir aber wenn wir das russische
Fernsehen anschauen noch weiter entfernt
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung das
war wie immer sehr erhellend und
informativ das war Gustav Gressl für uns
von der Denkfabrik European Council on
Foreign Relations Dankeschön und einen
schönen Abend nach Berlin guten Abend
danke sehr und euch natürlich auch
wieder ein herzliches Dankeschön wie
immer auch bei diesem Thema viele
Zuschriften viele Fragen und Kommentare
ganz herzlichen Dank wir wünschen euch
einen schönen Abend und vor allem auch
ein schönes Wochenende bis nächste Woche
macht's gut ciao ciao